[Music]
bismillah everything with us we don't
really have a word where do you table
manners come from and what do they say
about us I always see as there's no
point presenting ourselves well with
what you wear
if you can't have proper table manners
it's kind of like wearing a nice suit
but not having a good hygiene what are
your biggest gripes I've really enjoyed
it when people blow their nose at the
table leak even though don't eat too
quickly don't have big bites maybe they
made a mess
maybe we'll putting dirty elbows on a
clean table in medieval times when
tables were simply boards balanced over
trestles it avoided tipping the long
table and gave room to your neighbor in
times when the tablecloth was the napkin
it was best to keep your elbows where a
used to it makes me feel more powerful
the importance of manners rocketed
during the Renaissance as a way of
implying civility sophistication and
status even the simplest of foods
developed complicated rules do it like
this I don't know how to describe that I
believe the correct way to use the soup
spoon is to hold it in your right hand
and to take the soup away from you and
then to sit from the soup spoon and we
never blow the food because if you do it
everything can be as presence everywhere
I just don't eat you don't I tend to
dislike when people make noise while
eating
you're allowed to make noise especially
when you Roman
especially when it comes to soups
[Music]
it's not nice in it it looks around the
world we use all sorts of different
tools including our hands to eat in
France in 1699 pointed knives were
bounded at the table because there was a
very real risk of snappings
that's where we get the fork and blunt
knives we tend to use today in parts of
Asia all this was avoided by the use of
chopsticks which in China have been used
for over 3,000 years using chopsticks
keeps you fit involving over 30 joints
and 50 muscles but they come with their
own social rules you're not allowed to
stab your chopsticks vertically because
this kind of like replicates when you're
at like a funeral trying to pay respect
for someone they normally like put
incense into soil and stuff so that's
like that the whole idea of it this is a
fish knife never used one of these we
rarely rarely see these these days
mainly because the fish we get now is
fileted where we used to get it on the
bone and I think the use of the fish
knife was to clear the fish from the
bones knife and fork is wonderful bed
it's as if you're feeding someone else
you are not in touch with your food even
aristocrats eats chicken with their
hands so do the same thing and and
finish the bone I believe the food
tastes better because you get to lick
your finger
the rules are endless but did they
really matter cool time is saint-germain
timeline if you kind of enjoy you don't
hurt somebody if you can't enjoy you
don't disrespect somebody then why are
you putting rules it's definitely a way
for for people in the upper class or in
the middle class to feel superior to
people that just want to eat with with
their fork the basis of manners is
respect respectful for the food respect
for the cook respect for your fellow
guests the food is not just for survival
it's not just so that you can carry on
it's it's a social thing food really is
the glue that sticks friends together
and family and relatives it has to be
enjoyed it has to be fun it has to be
with people so maybe we should forget
the rules and that dinner just be fun as
long as you don't lick your chopsticks
though your nose salad leaves thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
click the bail to receive notifications
for new videos see you again soon